hello everybody today the channel is
three years old I can hardly believe it
exactly three years ago today I started
this channel after my first channel got
banned on YouTube and it kind of turned
into something bigger than I ever
thought possible
and I was trying to think of something I
could do you know to celebrate in making
a video for you guys but in the end I
just wanted to make today absolutely
about you guys so all day long today I
will be posting your fan art to Facebook
I will be responding to people on
Twitter I'll be responding to people in
the comments and I created a very
special playlist of your favorite videos
over the past three years so in the
comments below please write your
favorite video that I've done in the
past because there's over 2000 of them
like over 2200 videos that I've done in
3 years and that's astonishing to think
about but just thank you guys you know
thank you guys so much for being here
with me on this journey and thank you so
much for supporting me for so long I
know I just did a vlog yesterday but I
couldn't not do something else to tell
you guys thank you for being here for
three whole years and I know it's not
gonna end anytime soon and I know that
there's not gonna be an end date that I
have in mind but just thank you so much
for supporting me for so long I love you
guys you're awesome
I hope you enjoyed that as much as I did
so thanks again everybody for watching
and let's get on with the celebration
see in the comments down below
[Music]